I think the world would end if leaving
aside all these other catastrophes and
and leaving aside the possibility that
they could completely destroy earth
which is not clear I think that the the
real end of earth will take place when
the Sun which is now a very average star
on what we call the main sequence stage
of evolution when the Sun runs out of
hydrogen in its core it's building up
helium right now when this happens the
Sun will drastically change its
structure when it uses up hydrogen it no
longer has thermonuclear fusion energy
to provide its new luminosity those it's
shiny because of thermonuclear fusion of
hydrogen and helium when that hydrogen
fuel source runs out the Sun will
drastically change its structure and
evolve into what we call a red giant
star a red giant star is one like for
example you may be familiar with Antares
which is the brightest star in the
constellation scorpius it's a very red
star it's a red supergiant star another
example is baitul jews in the
constellation Orion famous wintertime
constellation here in the northern
hemisphere these these stars these red
supergiant's are example interiors if
you placed it where the Sun is located
our orbit would be inside of that star
so I think the ultimate end of the earth
is going to be when the Sun expands to a
red giant its outer layers swell up to
beyond 93 million miles earth will then
start to experience viscous drag as it
orbits the red giant Sun this viscous
drag will cause the orbit of Earth to
decay much like an artificial satellite
that we launched around Earth will
eventually burn up in the atmosphere
earth will eventually be incinerated
inside the Sun Mercury Venus and Earth
and possibly Mars will undergo what we
call death spirals their orbits will be
K as they lose or berlanga momentum due
to the viscous drag they will decay and
spiral into the Sun where they encounter
very high temperatures and essentially
earth will vaporize now this won't
happen for
or at least well the Sun has
approximately 5.4 billion more years as
a main sequence star then a few hundred
million years beyond that so i would say
in roughly six six billion years from
now the inner planet should be engulfed
by the red giant Sun but by then
presumably advanced life here on earth
will have colonized other worlds and so
we don't worry about it but but I think
that's the I think that's the perhaps
the best answer to your question is that
eventually it's got to happen the Sun
will become a red giant star and the
inner planets will then decay and and
burn up inside the Sun vaporize and then
Jupiter will start to accumulate mass
and if Jupiter accumulates more hydrogen
rich gas then it's then its present mass
its present mass is one one-thousandth
the sun's mass if Jupiter accretes about
ten others say roughly it reaches ten
times its present mass and it could do
this by by sweeping up solar gas as it
orbits the Sun with the future the
future resident giant Sun it could
undergo a thermonuclear ignition and
become a star and so you'd have the Sun
and Jupiter as a binary system but this
is of course something that is billions
of years into the future